[Music]
guys
linus just built a computer for us and
sent it to our office and i have it in a
box
right over here who wants to open it
with me
all i know is that linus told us that
our computers are too slow
he's like this is the best fastest
computer i've ever made and i'm gonna
give it to you i was like that's really
nice for you
holy cow yeah i mean a few years back we
made a video calling him up for
complaining about the red camera sarcasm
and jokes going on in that video i mean
there was some hype going on i mean i
was kind of
i was kind of serious where's the screen
just give me a macbook man
i mean you know maybe this is like an
olive branch they're kind of like you
know what
water under the bridge we're just gonna
send you the fastest computer we've ever
built
oh dude i'm seeing some specs already
yeah whoa
all right oh this is one of those like
slim cases oh yeah he put a nice compact
case for us
i think this must be the computer
[Music]
just give me a macbook man remove tape
before
filming it's like some sort of joke like
maybe it's like an ironic case like
inside out of the 30 90s
[Music]
it's got a ball oh there's hair in it
you know the whole thing about how he's
setting up a powerful computer is
actually a joke this is planned
linus has purposely built us an old mac
with photoshop
1.0 on this so we're going to be taking
jobs on fiverr
and doing the jobs in photoshop 1.0 and
we're going to send people the results
and see if they're happy with our work
or they can even tell the difference
this is going to be the ultimate test
in our vfx skills and our creativity can
idea
surmount technical limitations or are we
only as good as our gpus
we'll find out guys he sent us a piece
of history this isn't what i was
expecting but this is like legit
is that a floppy disk insert this is a
floppy disk insert
this is where you put the save button to
enable your save feature
this is macintosh lc475 this is a 1993
powerhouse guys
hey thanks for building us a wonderful
powerful workstation
oh yeah uh i must have gotten mixed up
in the mail because that's not what i
meant to send you you guys played with
this before you sent it our way right
yes we did how was your experience with
it what stood out to you
there were two things that stood out to
me about it before we sent it your way
number one
was how utterly unusable it was
it's just too slow but also how
shockingly functional
it was i was able to google things
about what i was doing and get real
answers what kind of
30 plus year old machine can do that i
remember reading the spec sheet that
this thing ran at 25 megahertz that's
25 million hertz that's a lot of hurts
remember too though that frequency
is not everything but pretty much any
modern
high performance processor whether it's
in a phone whether it's a cpu whether
it's a graphics card is running
well in excess of a billion hertz now
and a billion is a lot more than a
million
when you guys are trying to set this
thing up did you like what kind of
headaches did you run into
without talking to anthony who honestly
did the bulk of the work i can tell you
the main things that gave us problems
were figuring out
how to get files on and off of this
thing and then number two was figuring
out how to capture it in a way that's
not just reliable
but actually looks half decent because
as you guys know at the end of the day
we got a job to do we need to make a
video here and if you can't get good
clean capture off of it the audience is
just going to be looking at this blurry
pixelated mess
it's going to be audience really reacts
to bad vfx by corridor basically
our video is super focused on the ins
and outs of how we got the capture
working
how we got file transfers on and off of
the machine working
and what you can still do on a machine
like this well i guess we'd have to go
to your channel to find out wouldn't we
you would have to do that yes you would
a bit of a bear even though we've given
it to you guys all set up
we can figure this out right here we got
vga
we got vga to dvi this goes on a
construction site
there's only one plug in the computer so
you have to plug the mouse
into the keyboard you keep saying read
the instructions like you think we've
never
used computers before so uh we actually
have instructions
so i'm going to follow them here's your
ossc
ossc into the hdmi splitter i love old
tech like this
this would be like my old man hobby
these are like hieroglyphs man
somebody in the future finds one of
these
we were moments away from booting this
thing up i don't want to hear a buzz
noise
dude that was the most like the most
hoarse
apple boot sound it's like it was like
[Music]
this mouse so smooth it works like glass
adobe photoshop this is the same
photoshop that john nole and his brother
coated together and sold to adobe
oh yeah that sound
[Music]
oh there's a folder labeled games
princess
doom was obviously a revolutionary game
when it came out
and it's funny looking back at it now
i'm going oh wow the graphics
it's so crazy how low resolution how
janky this all looks compared to modern
day graphics
but thinking about my eight-year-old
self at the time um there was a game
called marathon which was awesome
they don't have this game on here i
don't think you would run no sam
[Music]
dude they have it on here yeah no one
told me
oh my god enough games we gotta get back
to work
we have photoshop 1.0 on here so griffin
is our resident artist he's the man who
actually uses photoshop for his job
every day
what's the oldest version of photoshop
you used i think the oldest i've used
was like
maybe cs2 cs3 i like the old icon they
should go back to that
give us your first impressions oh do
that splash screen
okay so new
wow okay this is very interesting here
in the color mode
the only options we have are grayscale
and rgb there is no
cmyk photo editing so i'm looking at the
tools
and we have a couple of the basics we
have round marquee we have rectangular
marquee we have the lasso
the quick selection tool guys there's no
pen tool serious i don't know if i can
do this
there's so few filters it's just one
menu gaussian blur we got we got the
the big boy in here this is kind of
impressive that it has all this stuff in
version one
like let's say you just draw something
like make a happy face dude that's
displaying the color oh
[Music]
beautiful let's see if i can make this
um
where's the brackets button how do i
make my brush bigger
wait does this not have brackets it
doesn't
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the key to all visual effects
one step you can make anything
i want to see this on a different
computer save this image what can you
save it as
photoshop pixar a tiff
i realize that there's no layers panel
as far as i can tell
there's no layers in photoshop one this
is like
real paint brushing throw a funky filter
on this i want to see i want to see how
long it takes to just run a filter
what's uh what's custom dot dot dot if
you don't see anything in here you like
you could always uh order something
custom
no idea what i'm looking at man this
looks like a cryptic puzzle
whoa look at that my first impression is
i'm very impressed by how much stuff
this came with but i'm also impressed by
how far it's come
it's kind of amazing how much the new
photoshop can do
you know when you look back at where it
started
bang you can't just play what oh
they haven't changed this freaking menu
in like 30 years
[Laughter]
all right these artists need to stop
messing around we have 75
open orders our reputation is on the
line it's gonna be
our work stacked up against people using
the most cutting-edge hardware most
cutting-edge software sam do you think
we can compete
i'm gonna start just dishing out jobs to
each artist they're probably gonna only
have 10 minutes
per job because we got to start knocking
these out simply said a selfie of his
face and he says can you please look my
face look like that of a snail
a little goofy photoshop action this is
right up my alley see what you can do
okay shouldn't be too hard to make you
look like a snail it's nail one dot
tip okay beautiful that'll do this guy
looking for some album art for his
upcoming album wow okay
what's the genre up here the band name
is called middle child syndrome
the album title maintenance issues i'm
gonna guess pop punk
all right let's sketch this out this
this little alien is the middle child
here we go the third arm is going to
point up at the the name of the album
username rumble works on this series he
needs a makeover he wants
80 style 80s style we gotta make him a
new logo
and we're doing a gradient purple to
deep
nighttime desaturated blue boom oh nice
they need the background replaced this
is their staff photo they would like the
background to place because the
location's not great and the balloons
are kind of in the way so if we could
paint out the balloon
okay oh my goodness that is a tiny ass
picture oh those are beautiful clouds
christian select all
copy we've got some high level photoshop
action happening here boys
there it is we've isolated our eye stock
we've grabbed a little bit of extra
meat off that bone that is going to be
very very cute
paste this on here great it looks great
free rotation we have a bounding box
oh they do this yeah it's just like the
real thing
all right fonts see what happens 50
points it's gonna be
bold it's gonna have shadow and outline
watch this
i'm about to do it again this time it's
not outlined or shadowed and i'm
stacking it manual drop shadow next tier
move
hey guys with the help of today's
sponsor squarespace
i'm going to be taking a few fiverr jobs
myself the guys don't know this but i'm
actually kind of an expert in microsoft
paint it's very similar to the tools
that they had back in
the photoshop one days so maybe we'll
learn a little bit about squarespace
along the way
first guy up is uh sir wadefx
he is looking for the album art of his
life
needs to include something anime related
gaming 2 if possible and maybe some
super powers
my cat luna has to approve of it she
expects nothing less than perfection all
right let's get a nice big canvas here
going and again
today's episode is sponsored by
squarespace the first thing that they do
for you is offer you a beautiful
award-winning template from which to
build
a beautiful website much like this
program is doing for me right now so
let's get started
[Music]
because we are going about this in a
team effort i think the fact that i can
work on some fiverr gigs
maybe sam and nico can take a few others
that tells me
that multiple contributors is key and
with squarespace
you can have multiple contributors
contribute to your website
and have different permissions for their
access to the site that makes it go
well beyond just making a janky image
or website in your living room
okay so the first one's done we're gonna
save this first sir wave and move on to
the next one
theodrosby he says he wants to have
a chunky boy look like a skinny boy now
it sounds like
theo is going to use this for some of
his social media profiles
with squarespace you can have connected
social media accounts
so meaning you can take things like your
twitter profile and you can post once
onto your squarespace and it will
automatically format from that post on
squarespace and go out to other social
media profiles and i think
this is exactly what theo needs here
[Music]
well i think we're done here you know i
think it looks great so
hopefully he loves it and last but not
least we've got seiseric who is asking
us
i would appreciate maybe a stream
overlay it can be as ridiculous
as humanly possible i just want to let
you guys know that squarespace has
members areas meaning that you can
create memberships with your squarespace
site and have people
come in and participate as members on
your website so
go ahead and get that going on just like
i'm about to get this render going on
it's going to be out of this world
[Music]
all right well this is citrix render i
don't know if it's as ridiculous as
humanly possible but it's pretty much
out there i mean out of this world right
and you guys can create something out of
this world with
your own squarespace they even have
things like video blocks so if you guys
are streaming you can take those videos
put them
into your squarespace website the
traffic overviews tool allow you to
understand who's coming to your site
where they're coming from and then how
to better optimize your site you guys
are interested
in starting your own squarespace website
head on over to squarespace.com
corridor crew to get to 10 off the first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com
coral crew all right back to it what
other jobs they got on here
blendin fam look at this whoa oh my god
i'm so
good at photoshop even if it's old so
we're we're very close to being done
here
we're blending in just where the eye
stalks connect
griffin's doing a wonderful job no
caniko i am
what do hearts look like all right let's
get enough gotta get those big alien
eyes in there
i'm going for more of it like a
hand-drawn look here i mean a hand draw
like ms paint hand-drawn
you know i'm running out of room
honestly that's pretty good we're
forcing the sun to work in this
i'm just going to invert my selection
here and put a cool sun behind it oh yes
yes i'm doing my 80s lines there you go
i could only undo months damn it oh
we're redoing it i don't care it's an
80s grid it doesn't matter don't worry
i can i can salvage it all right last
thing we have to do we're going to add
their eyes
90 that doesn't look half bad i should
try to clone stamp over the person's
nostrils
[Music]
[Laughter]
keep it
so there we go you got four nostrils now
you're welcome all right i think we're
good it's a great photoshop right there
if you show that to somebody in 1991
you would blow their mind their eyes
would actually do that for real all
right send it out christian
deliver the snail photo actually not
gonna lie that's pretty freaking sweet
all right i'm done i'm cool
all right file save as i'm done that's
it we're done no contrast adjustments
they're getting what they get
it's a beautiful picture honestly the
clouds in the sky match pretty well nice
job niko
thank you now speaking of art there is
there's one thing we wanted to do
we were wondering if we could get a job
from you like if you want like a photo
retouched or you want a logo designed
oh i would be happy to give you guys an
assignment so
we are actually working on launching an
apple specific
channel this is something people don't
really know yet but we have already
hired people to work on it
i would like you guys to take a crack at
it
and see if you can beat my graphic
designer
and design a logo that is competitive
for the channel
all right we'll do that we'll go see it
that's gonna not be me
i'm thinking maybe like 100 pixels by
100 pixels so you want a little more
high-res than that
you know what whatever the machine can
do i'll accept it
we're gonna get to work we're gonna make
sure you're impressed you won't even
know that this is made in photoshop 1.0
by the way i think i'll know
but i'll pretend i don't know for you
okay just for you oh thank you
that means a lot all right thanks linus
i appreciate it
all right thanks guys bye hey everybody
at the
linus group i hope you guys are doing
all right i want to say thank you for
the opportunity to take a shot at
designing the new logo for your mac
address channel
so yeah doing this logo took me a couple
hours it might only take me a couple
minutes these days
but there's something really special
about doing it on authentic macintosh
hardware
now there's a couple cutting edge
technological features
in this logo that i think you guys might
want to hear a little bit about for
example
the color transfer modes on linus face
well that is a
brand new technique well brand new as of
that is achievable only in something
like photoshop 1.0 now you might also
notice this nice
soft anti-aliased edges around linus's
head well masking like that only be
achieved on one of these cutting-edge
pieces of hardware and the text itself
also anti-aliased that's right these
kind of things
you might expect to pay 900 an hour for
on a
specifically built piece of hardware
just to do this kind of design but you
know what with something like myself i
can do it on my home computer
just manipulating the image in any
regard takes about a minute
no you can't really play with it it's
like building an actual structure you
kind of have to have a blueprint a plan
already laid out
go for it and you follow your plan and
hopefully it works out anyways i won't
be offended if you don't decide to use
my logo submission
i look forward to hearing what you guys
think it's definitely a little basic
wow that is not as good as i expected
i uh uh wow yeah i hmm
how long did it take him to do that
where do i start with this
you've got three different greens uh
what happened there
well the apple logo actually has two
different greens in it there's a yellow
green
and a regular green that's the third
the third one is actually sampled from
the same green but the thing is once you
do a color overlay
in photoshop on your face and of course
it switches the hue just a little bit
and any sort of like manipulation of the
image takes about a minute to calculate
so it's not really a train of thought
kind of thing it's not really working at
the speed of creativity it's more like
i set a plan at the beginning and then
whenever you arrive at the end is what
you're left with and that's as good as
you get
the lack of undo unless you saved like
almost
every change you made this pencil has no
eraser
and look there's a little bit of there's
a little there's a little floating
floating bit of yellow here just kind of
hanging out
i doubt you're gonna have as easy an
explanation for why you spelled a dress
wrong oh damn it
what was the rationale there did you not
notice till now
i didn't notice until now
but in fairness to you photoshop i don't
think god integrated spell checking
until like a couple years ago
never mind in 1990s so well
it was a valley and it was a valiant
effort this was this was a ton of fun
i'm glad you guys reached out and i'm
glad we were able to do it
because anthony man that guy is a hero
there's no way i would have been able to
figure out
all the little bits that he did
especially not
in like a timely manner we would have
been working on this collab in like two
years
well this is a total blast and uh i
don't know if you guys
have any other wacky computer ideas that
you ever want to do in the future
i'm 100 down so they say that
it doesn't matter what tools you're
using it matters what ideas you have
and i think with this video we
discovered that that saying is not 100
true
definitely having better tools makes
your job easier
if you don't have good tools your ideas
need to be really really really good
so yeah in this case having a newer
computer or a newer version of photoshop
yeah it would definitely help especially
with features like layers
you know and all that good stuff thanks
to linus thanks to anthony thanks to all
the people over there
you guys should definitely go check out
linus tech tips if you haven't it's a
great tech
channel they upload videos every day
they're super entertaining thanks for
watching everybody
see you in the next one so earlier this
week we sent off our finished work to
our clients on fiverr
and they sent us some feedback let's see
what they have to say about our work
oh my god
the helicopter oh
bro oh
i mean i like it so they gave us an
upside down star inside of a heart
and i i think those are flames
you know it's not what i was expecting
it it's
beautiful and fantastic but it is not
what i was thinking was going to happen
wow okay uh kind of janky
it's kind of uh really poorly done i
mean you get what you pay for
so this is what five dollars worth of
art
is worth it truly is terrible